let me start leasing Congrats on the
show five episodes in I cannot wait to
finish the last five I don't want to say
because I'm gonna air this breath or you
know what I mean yeah I'm just gonna the
thing about the show that I will say
that this fair game is there's a lot of
WTF things right um you know talk a
little bit about when you guys first got
approached for the series how much did
you know about where it was all gonna go
and how much he's sort of like well it's
night it's gonna be good
the the latter immediately I was that's
how I thought and I came to it and
Lauren was already attached and I love
her work and was like I want to do this
and I knew who Sean was and I
desperately wanted to do it but every
time we came to reread the episode as a
cast I was like wait did I miss that
totally and we got all we got 9 episodes
to start so there's tons of time when we
do the full cast read as I missed that
completely so always saying WTF yeah you
know I mean Nate's being at the helm of
this was definitely a big draw for me I
wanted to be in a thriller I've never
been in one and to work with master of
the genre seemed like a pretty safe
place to be as an actor because this is
a really challenging character which is
what I liked about it it's a strange
lady just struggling um well one of the
things that I actually really dig about
the show is that it's very it what
happens is realistic in this situation
like it's not you know like it's playing
it like what if this really happened and
it's not happen you don't I mean not
interested that's what night does he has
the characters at one Tambor playing it
real and playing it straight and being
in their world and then underneath
there's all of these like tectonic
plates shifting and all these swirling
crazy supernatural energies that the
characters that we as a family aren't
even aware of and I feel like that's his
that's a thing that he does quite
magically
it from a point of view of what if this
had happened where are you if this
happens to you and your wife where are
you this is your brother-in-law where
are you if suddenly this stranger is in
your house you know completely um I had
to look away from the screen during the
Eocene that was the nastiest day I've
ever been on a set no vomitted that she
actually worked in a bucket she she said
that to me on camera there's a lot of
work but again it was something that was
written in the script and everyone was
very excited about and then I went into
the kitchens and I was like hey we have
to skin an eel and they're like oh don't
do that it's impossible work I was like
what do you mean like the real sex we're
saying like you mustn't don't do that
you got to nail it to a wood and board
the skin underneath the blood is and we
wrote on see if you get it in your mouth
tomorrow we'll go get four eels so we
went down to the fish eerie delivery Bay
wherever it is and we go like the
Italian market we go pick up these eels
that someone's called and got from the
Fisher from New York and they bring them
in and we get them and you have to nail
that poor thing to a board and cut it in
a V and then try and get your fingers
with rubber gloves on under the skin and
that's Toby's research but on the set I
will let you know that Noel was harm oh
yeah yeah no really it was unbelievable
how crazy crazy switcheroo surgery we
had really in the thing we had the guys
from animal humane society and we had
the man I picked up the eel and I'm
talking to Lauren and then I bring the
heel down and drew drew the chef's down
there and I'm caught into a little
bucket and handed me a little rubber
heel so I could bomb it's a stunning
absolutely stunning you yeah yeah no III
everyone's would say we do there were
dead eels they were alive
there was a drill animating a bit look I
mean here's the thing ultimately though
I had to look away from the screen and I
think a lot of people will experience
what I did which is yeah yes exactly
when you guys think back besides the
eole day when you think back in the
making of the show is there like a day
or two you're always gonna remember what
was that like really the one that just
is it was actually I have tons of fun
memories and what was nice actually
about playing the chef is I got we had a
little satellite kitchen separate from
the real the kitchen on set which worked
and I spent a lot my time with drew
cooking and figuring out these things we
cooked an actual haggis and it smelt so
bad yeah right by aware all the props
and that was a huge complaint so we had
to just make a huge sausage in the end
we didn't do it an actual haggis I had
some news reports that we're really out
there and fun to do but I I don't want
to divulge them because funny I'm
picking engross I had some like gross oh
whatever
one of the things I really like about
the way Apple does their shows is that
you get a few at once and then it's
weekly and I'm because it allows people
to have like that public conversation
because everyone can see yeah right and
so I wanted to know what's your thoughts
on this and maybe what's the last thing
you benched mm-hmm I well I love it I
love the idea because you get a little
bit of a binge and it helps you get into
the show because I started watching this
shows that came out first you know Drake
I mean Snoopy I watched all of them
because there's no chief to have more
but the morning show I was like how
watch you you know so it works I think
really well and it gives you that
feeling of like God it's Friday and
thing I can catch up on my shows mm-hmm
I rewatched all of the Sopranos while we
were shooting the show okay there's a
binge binge watch this
it's yeah what your thoughts on the
whole weekly thing I like I like the
weekly I like I'm an old-fashioned kind
of person I like the old-fashioned you
know wait for it marinate on it imagine
what might happen talk about it with
your friends look forward it's an event
make popcorn this kind of thing I'll
tell you what someone runs a website
it's much better for us to have
something that people who talk about
every week right rather than having an I
here it all is yeah gotta go
Congrats on the show man can't wait to
finish it thank you